Kate Spade's husband is revealing
details of her mental health struggles
Andy spade says the fashion designer
suffered from depression and was
actively seeking help she was found dead
Tuesday of an apparent suicide dr.
Jeffrey Lieberman is chairman of
Psychiatry at Columbia University's
College of Physicians and Surgeons
we should note he did not treat Kate
Spade personally dr. levo good morning
Thank You Kate Spade's husband says that
there was no indication and no warning
that something like this was going to
happen how unusual is that and what are
those warning signs a suicide does not
just happen out of the blue I mean 90
percent of the people who commit suicide
have an antecedent psychiatric condition
now despite the conflicting comments by
family members about whether she was or
wasn't in treatment or was there was
until it's pretty certain that she had
some pre-existing condition likely a
mood disorder depression or bipolar
disorder if she wasn't getting treatment
and because if the stigma and
embarrassment was deterring her
that's just shameful and unacceptable
and even if she was getting treatment
then why did this happen
there it's possible I'm not disputing
him but it's hard to believe that there
was not some indications of the fact
that she was at risk and thus there
should have been some so what are some
of those warning signs that someone
might be considering suicide well first
if people begin to sort of isolate
themselves no longer invest themselves
in the activities that they'd previously
been doing they seem to be more
emotionally distressed than previously
their sleep might be disturbed they say
things like though life isn't worth
living or I just don't have the
interested in anymore but the biggest
predictor is whether they have a
pre-existing mood disorder because
that's the highest associated risk
factor and then if they have other
things family history substance abuse an
adverse life event like marital discord
or professional reverses say you know
somebody who has some of these signs
what do you do as someone who loves them
to tell
people tend to tiptoe around sensitive
issues like suicide or anything but you
shouldn't
you're not gonna prompt somebody to do
it by asking them so you talk to them
you know I've noticed you've been
looking down or I've noticed you've said
things that seem like you know you're
really not as motivated to towards life
these are a problem and if they say
something about you know I feel like my
life is really empty say have you ever
thought about ask them and then say we
need to get help and if you then are
concerned there is an actual protocol
for suicide prevention which involves
don't leaving them alone removing
objects that can be used and taking them
to see a doctor the Kate Spade story is
also emblematic of what is now growing
suicide rate in this country is this a
public health emergency it is and it has
been it's like many things in mental
health care it's not gotten the
attention it's due it's one of the top
ten causes of death all the others heart
disease cancer auto accidents have gone
down decade over decade suicide goes up
and Kate Spade in the female
demographics was right in the age range
where its highest for women well talking
about it is one step to combatting and
dr. Lieberman thank you for your time
if you are having suicidal thoughts or
would like to speak with someone the
Suicide Prevention lifeline number is